starting off this hour is Mitch in
Oakland California I'm Mitch how are you
good Dave I doing today better than I
deserve
what's up so um we have some debt we
just started your process and my wife
would like to pay off the car first
which we have about $7,000 on it
and I kind of just want to stick to the
process and pay off the the smallest one
first mm-hmm and so I mean we have about
$47,000 with a random debt you know
credit car and how many how many other
debts are smaller than the car debt like
three other ones okay
how quickly will they be paid off
probably after we get our tax refund
right after that okay so a couple months
and we don't we yeah a couple months so
really like well we're discussing here's
a couple months yes okay well I think
that's not true I think we're discussing
more than a couple months because I
think we're discussing whether or not
we're going to follow a plan that is
proven correct or whether we're going to
make up our own plan correct and you're
grownups you get to do whichever one you
want to do but you know I've got a
friend of mine that has lost 82 pounds I
asked him how he did that because I
would be interested not losing 82 I
don't need to lose 82 but it's just it's
a it's an admirable thing he's pulled
off you know he lost her back straight
yeah you know I mean he's it's amazing
and so then he tells me the three things
he did and if I say well I you know okay
that's cool if I want to have the
results he's had what would I do
I would do the three things he did why
would I do two of the things he did and
one of the things I wanted to do it's
not logical and so this is really what
you guys have got to get down to is um
when I went broke when I went broke
because I was so freaking stupid you
know what I had to come to was my plan
doesn't work I need a new plan and so
you know your all's best thoughts have
got you to where you are
they're not working for ya you know
right and so that's the kind of thing
and you know husband wife person I have
to do it with me too so I'm not picking
on her Mitch but there's a thing here
that you it's kind of like I have to
admit I don't know because what I know
got us here if I'm her and I'm you and
so you guys do whatever you want to do
I'm not picking at you but there's kind
of a humility to say I don't know how to
do this I'm searching out someone that
does and I'm going to do what they did
versus I'm going to do my thing because
but because your track record on your
thing sucks you know I mean it's that
and I'm in the same situation I'm not
saying i'm any better but this is a
proven thing it's not like I made this
up three weeks ago and I'm trying to get
you to do it for the first time and it
may or may not work I mean 10 million
people have done this so you guys do
whatever you want to do but that's the
kind of thing I'm a little bit worried
about here is and you know you get a
little bit further down into this or two
years from now you finally do get out of
debt and you're going along and the car
transmission goes out and go in you know
I think I'll just get a car loan again
because you didn't change inside your
heart and that's what's concerning about
the conversation mathematically we're
discussing two months it doesn't matter
I mean if you wanted to pay off the car
first and instead of doing the debt
snowball it really probably is not going
to destroy your life you know it's not
going to cause you to go bankrupt or
something like that it's not like we're
gonna somebody yell at you for being
stupid but somewhere in this journey you
all are on you've got to address the
fact that the recipe for money you've
been using you know is not cooking up
well and we need to find a better recipe
and follow the recipe you know my wife
Sharon is a great cook but she's what we
call a country cook Mitch and that means
that she just puts a pinch of this and a
pinch of that in there and so a
Pinterest recipe is not really a recipe
for sharing it's kind of a guideline you
know she might put what's in there out
of the recipe she might just make up
something while she's going along it
generally turns out because she's a good
cook
but it for a nerd like me it drives me
crazy if I'm going to pull up a recipe
and like well I'm doing it a turkey at
Thanksgiving and we're gonna do the
brine and there's 47 things you want in
the brine and I give her that list I
want all 47 things on the counter
because I want to do what that person
did if I knew how to brine a turkey why
would I need a recipe you know it's that
kind of thing right and so she but she
substitutes crap and it drives me
bananas so it's the same kind of thing
to be there's a recipe if you want
chocolate cake here's the recipe you
want vanilla cake here's a recipe if you
want the life you've got now you already
know the recipe follow your best ideas
and so again I'm not trying to be err
going to pick on her or be mean to her
but that's the spirit that the two of
you need to talk through pray through
and decide you know what you're going to
do and it's okay we'll be friends if you
want to do your own thing go do your own
thing but this you know you can't say
you're doing Dave Ramsey plan and then
not do the plan that's what it comes
down to hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]